vamos a hablar de calor específico y el
calor de la fusión y vaporización
digamos que tenemos un contenedor con
algún líquido y queremos aumentar la
temperatura probablemente vamos a tener
que incluir una fuente de calor pero
cuánto calor debemos agregar hay una
fórmula para esto para calcular cuánto
calor debemos agregar dependerá de
varias cosas por ejemplo una de ellas
cuál es la cantidad en la que queremos
aumentar la temperatura mientras más
querramos aumentar la temperatura
tendremos que agregar más calor también
va a depender de qué tanto material
tenemos en otras palabras la masa de
este líquido de acá
mientras más tengamos más calor
tendremos que agregar para aumentar la
temperatura que queremos y también
depende de una cosa más
el calor específico de este material en
particular diferentes materiales
requerirán de diferente cantidad de
calor para aumentar su temperatura y si
un material tiene un calor específico
alto va a requerir más jules de calor
para aumentar su temperatura así que
un poco más específicos
digamos que el líquido es agua y está a
una temperatura de 20 grados celsius y
digamos que este es un contenedor grande
que contiene dos kilogramos de agua
el calor específico lo podemos encontrar
en ciertas tablas oa veces no nos dan
comodato en el caso del agua el calor
específico es de 4.186 jules por
kilogramo grados celsius y estas
unidades nos dan una idea de lo que
significa el calor específico nos dice
que el agua requiere de 4.186 jules para
calentar un kilogramo un grado celsius y
aquí nos damos cuenta de que va a
requerir de mucha energía para calentar
esta agua pues el agua tiene un calor
específico muy alto puede almacenar
mucha energía del calor sin elevar mucho
su temperatura y digamos que la pregunta
es cómo aumentar esa temperatura a 50
grados celsius cuánta energía del calor
tenemos que agregar para lograr este
incremento en la temperatura
pues la cantidad de calor que vamos a
necesitar es igual a la masa que es de 2
kilogramos multiplicada por el calor
específico que es 4.186 jules por
kilogramo grados celsius multiplicado
por el cambio de la temperatura esto es
la diferencia de temperatura temperatura
final menos temperatura inicial la
temperatura final es de 50 grados
celsius que es a donde queremos llegar
- la temperatura inicial que es de 20
grados celsius y ahora vamos a calcular
la cantidad de calor lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar todos estos
términos y nos va a dar 251 mil 160
jules que es muchísima energía
calorífica que es la necesaria para
incrementar la temperatura del agua 30
grados celsius por eso es que muchas
veces usamos el agua como disipador de
calor se puede poner mucho calor en el
agua sin que cambie demasiado su
temperatura
este ejemplo fue bastante simple vamos a
hacer otro un poquito más complejo
digamos que en lugar de calentar este
cubo con una llama por debajo voy a usar
un pedazo de metal caliente digamos que
tenemos un pedazo de cobre que tiene una
masa de 0.5 kilogramos y este cobre lo
dejamos acá en el agua lo calentamos y
lo dejamos caer en este contenedor y
queremos saber cuál va a ser la
temperatura de equilibrio que va a
alcanzar este pedazo de cobre cuál va a
ser el equilibrio de temperatura que va
a tener esto el cobre se va a enfriar el
agua se va a calentar y eventualmente
van a alcanzar el equilibrio a cierta
temperatura cuál va a ser esa
temperatura
pues vamos a necesitar varios datos ya
les he comentado la masa del cobre
necesitamos conocer su temperatura
inicial y comentamos que lo íbamos a
calentar mucho así que la temperatura
inicial del cobre es de 90 grados
celsius también necesitamos saber el
calor específico del cobre y resulta que
el calor específico del cobre es 387
jules por kilogramo grados celsius el
agua sigue teniendo las mismas
propiedades que vimos al inicio tiene
una masa de dos kilogramos el calor
específico siempre va a ser para el agua
4.186 jules por kilogramo grados celsius
y digamos que tiene una temperatura
inicial de 20 grados celsius y sabemos
que la temperatura de equilibrio la
temperatura que ambos materiales van a
alcanzar se va a encontrar entre los 20
y los 90 grados celsius y tenemos que
encontrar exactamente cuál va a ser el
rojo que vamos a usar es que si lo
pensamos el cobre
a perder calor y el agua va a ganar
calor pues van a tener que ser iguales
suponiendo que no tenemos calor que se
esté perdiendo en el ambiente así que
vamos a suponer que esto ocurre en un
calor y metro todo esto está aislado lo
que va a evitar que escape calor si no
escapa calor la temperatura que aumente
el agua va a ser la misma temperatura
que pierde el cubo de cobre básicamente
si sumamos el calor perdido por el cobre
más el calor absorbido o ganado por el
agua vamos a obtener cero ya que uno de
éstos va a ser negativo y el otro va a
ser positivo y tendrán el mismo valor
absoluto como encontramos esto pues
recuerden que tenemos una fórmula q es
igual a eme porsche por delta t y pueden
recordarlo imaginando que dice en cat ya
que tenemos esta se está delta pues
parece una am y tenemos la t q es igual
a m cat
vamos a usar la masa del cobre 0.5
kilogramos de cobre por su calor
específico que es de 387 jules
kilogramos celsius multiplicado por el
cambio en temperatura no sea la
temperatura final pero si conozco la
temperatura inicial vamos a llamar a
este dato que no sé de efe temperatura
final menos mi temperatura inicial que
si la tengo y es de 90 grados celsius
el calor ganado por el agua que podemos
usar la misma fórmula para calcularlo la
masa es de 2 kilogramos
el calor específico es de 4.186 jules
kilogramos celsius la temperatura final
aquí también la desconozco la nombro t
efe igual y le restó la temperatura
inicial esta sí la conozco 20 grados
celsius y tengo que lograr que todo esto
sea igual a 0 y esto puede lucir un poco
intimidante porque es una ecuación
bastante grande y tenemos nuestra
interrogante metida por acá y quizás se
pregunten bueno esto tiene solución
sí sí tiene solución sólo tenemos una
incógnita que este final estas dos en la
misma variable es la temperatura en la
que el agua y el cobre se van a
equilibrar el número que vamos a
encontrar de calcular toda esta parte
naranja va a ser un número negativo pues
el cobre va a perder energía calorífica
y el término del agua va a ser un
término positivo porque el agua va allá
la energía calorífica va a aumentar su
temperatura ambos se van a cancelar
dándonos 0 y es la condición que
necesitamos así que solo tendremos que
encontrar t final vamos a hacer toda la
multiplicación combinar los términos
semejantes y después de despejar t final
para encontrar su valor
multiplicamos todos los términos
voy a combinar los términos de mi té
final y los dos términos que no tienen
latte final
y todo lo voy a poner del otro lado de
la igualdad para calcular el valor de
este final
y va a resultar que me queda 21.58
grados celsius como temperatura final y
cuando vean esto me pueden decir parece
que nos equivocamos como es que es 21.58
grados celsius cuando la temperatura
inicial del agua fue de 20 grados
celsius apenas se logró aumentar su
temperatura casi 2 grados y en efecto es
lo que estamos diciendo este calor
específico del agua es tan alto que le
podemos agregar mucho calor y apenas va
a aumentar su temperatura ahora también
podemos tomar en cuenta que el
contenedor en sí mismo pudo haber
absorbido algo del calor por lo que
pudimos agregar otro término aquí con
referencia a la temperatura del
contenedor y tomarlo en cuenta para
estos cálculos o podemos agregar un cubo
de otro material aquí y agregar esa
temperatura acá si sumamos el calor de
todos los elementos involucrados en este
sistema que podrían ganar calor o perder
calor
todo esto va a ser igual a cero ya que
nada de la energía calorífica puede
salir de aquí o puede entrar ese calor
tiene que intercambiarse con los
elementos que se encuentran aquí adentro
ningún calor se va a crear o se va a
destruir simplemente se va a transferir
entre los materiales que se encuentran
aquí adentro esto es la clave para
resolver este tipo de problemas de calor
específico
lo dejamos de esta forma y después
calculamos nuestra incógnita que es la
temperatura final quizás en algunas
ocasiones no sepamos cuál va a ser la
masa de algún material o el calor
específico de algún otro material sin
embargo vamos a despejar en términos de
lo que queremos calcular
hagamos otra pregunta digamos que
tomamos la misma cantidad de agua 2
kilogramos con una temperatura de 20
grados celsius pero ahora quiero saber
cuánto calor debo agregar para que esta
agua se vuelva vapor que toda esta agua
hierva y se vuelva a vapor lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es llevar todo
esto a la temperatura de ebullición la
temperatura de ebullición del agua es de
100 grados celsius primero tengo que
usar m-cat ms del tate
la masa es de 2 kilogramos el calor
específico es de 4.186 jules por
kilogramo grados celsius él gana la
temperatura si sabemos que la
temperatura de ebullición del agua es de
100 grados celsius y sabemos que la
temperatura inicial es de 20 grados
celsius tenemos que de final es 100
grados celsius de iniciales 20 grados
celsius por lo que el calor necesario
para llevar a esto a su punto de
ebullición es de 669 1760 más o menos
aproximadamente
jules pero esto no es lo suficiente para
que hierva o esté en ebullición toda el
agua apenas es la temperatura necesaria
para que esta agua alcance los 100
grados celsius esto no es suficiente si
ustedes elevan la temperatura del agua a
100 grados celsius y la dejan así va a
permanecer así y no va a hervir no va a
bullir
y seguir agregando calor para que se dé
esto que tanto más calor hay que agregar
una vez que nuestra agua ha alcanzado la
temperatura de 100 grados celsius para
que volvamos toda esta agua vapor para
esto necesitamos conocer el calor de
fusión y vaporización en este caso como
está hirviendo vamos a necesitar el
calor de vaporización ya que estamos
volviendo a un líquido en vapor si
pasamos de un sólido a un líquido sería
fusión la fórmula de calor de fusión o
vaporización es q la cantidad de calor
que tenemos que agregar para cambiar la
fase de este material el calor de fusión
vaporización nos hace que cambiemos de
fase y el calor específico se refiere a
que tanta cantidad de calor es necesaria
para cambiar la temperatura a 80 grados
celsius y este otro cálculo nos dice que
una vez que ya llegamos a los 100 grados
celsius que tanto calor hay que agregar
demás para lograr el cambio de fase
de toda esta agua hacia vapor la fórmula
del calor de fusión o vaporización luce
así q es igual a m por l m es la masa
mientras más masa tengamos más calor
tendremos que agregar para hacer el
cambio de fase l es el calor latente de
fusión o de vaporización y es un número
parecido al calor específico pero en
lugar de decirnos que tanto calor
tenemos que agregar para lograr un
cambio de temperatura esto nos dice que
tanto calor tenemos que agregar para
hacer el cambio de fase y resulta que el
calor latente de vaporización del agua
es algo enorme son dos millones 260 mil
jules por kilogramo
se requieren dos millones 260 mil tools
a vaporizar un kilogramo de agua que ya
se encuentre a 100 grados celsius de
temperatura y transformar esto en un
kilogramo de vapor así que si yo quiero
transformar estos dos kilogramos de agua
en vapor a partir de los 20 grados
celsius que ya tiene de temperatura
tengo que agregarle el calor calculado
con ms del tate para llegar a los 100
grados celsius y ya esto tengo que
agregarle otra cantidad de calor
la cantidad m por l 2 kilogramos de masa
por l que son 2 millones 260 mil soles
por kilogramo
así que necesitamos de 669 1760 jules
para lograr que el agua alcance los 100
grados celsius de temperatura y a esto
hay que agregarle otros 4 millones 520
mil jules para lograr transformar todo
esto en vapor
y en total necesitamos cinco millones
189 mil setecientos sesenta jules para
llevar esta agua desde los 20 grados
celsius y transformarla en dos
kilogramos de vapor ahora una cosa más
que les quiero mostrar y vamos a limpiar
lo que hicimos anteriormente es que
imaginemos que en lugar de iniciar con
agua comenzamos con un gran pedazo de
hielo de tres kilogramos de masa y esto
está muy frío no está a cero grados esto
tiene una temperatura inicial de menos
40 grados celsius lo que yo quiero saber
es qué tanto calor hay que agregar para
volver a este bloque de 3 kilogramos de
hielo en 3 kilogramos de vapor de agua
pero no quiero llegar solo a que se
transforme en vapor
quiero que este vapor tenga una
temperatura final de 160 grados celsius
cuánto calor tengo que agregar aquí para
poder llevar esto de un bloque de hielo
con temperatura inicial de menos
40 grados celsius hasta vapor de agua
con una temperatura final de 160 grados
celsius para que puedan visualizar mejor
esto voy a graficar la temperatura en mi
eje vertical como función de que tanto
calor se le agrega el sistema permítanme
mostrarles cómo no hacer esto una
aproximación no muy buena podría ser m
porsche delta t m es 3 kilogramos
michelle ahorita vemos cuál es el valor
de estas en ibi delta te puede ser mi
temperatura final 160 grados menos de
temperatura inicial que es menos 40 y
pues aquí escribo mi calor específico
hago mis cálculos y pues ya obtengo mi
temperatura pero esto no lo podemos
hacer así en primera que el calor
específico vamos a usar el calor
específico del agua
el calor específico del hielo de agua o
el calor específico del vapor de agua
todos tienen un calor específico
diferente y en segundo lugar vamos a
tener cambios de fase
primero el hielo se va a volver a agua
más adelante
el agua se va a transformar en vapor y
no podemos dejar de lado estos cambios
de fase por lo que esto no es la forma
de resolverlo lo que debemos hacer es
comenzar con nuestros menos 40 grados
celsius es el que esto está por encima
del eje de aquí pero imaginemos que en
este punto de aquí este origen no
comienza en cero al menos en el eje
vertical y vamos a ir agregando calor
que nos va a llevar esta temperatura a
cero grados y aquí tenemos que
detenernos cuando llegamos a cero grados
vamos a tener un cambio de fase y
tenemos que detenernos en cada cambio de
fase cuánto calor corresponde esta parte
de aquí usamos q igual a ms delta t m es
3 kilogramos
el calor específico del hielo es de 2
mil 93 kilogramos celsius
la temperatura final es 0 - la
temperatura inicial que es menos 40 y no
nos olvidemos de incluir este signo
negativo si calculamos todo esto
obtenemos que el calor necesario es de
250 1800 jules
esto solo es para llevar el hielo al
punto en el que comienza a derretirse
pero tenemos que derretirlo como vamos a
ver esto mientras se está derritiendo el
hielo bueno pues la temperatura va a
lucir constante conforme derretimos el
hielo la temperatura no va a cambiar y
toda esta energía se va a ocupar en
romper todos estos enlaces convirtiendo
este hielo en agua a cuánto calor
corresponde este segmento de acá es un
cambio de fase tenemos que usar la
fórmula correspondiente
tenemos que usar q igual a m por l
ms es kilogramos el calor latente de
aquí no va a ser el mismo que usamos
anteriormente que era el de vaporización
este calor latente tiene que ser el que
corresponde a un sólido volviéndose
líquido es el calor de fusión lo que
necesitamos y el calor de fusión latente
para el agua es de 333 mil soles por
kilogramo lo que nos da 999 mil jules de
calor
es solamente para volver este hielo que
está a una temperatura de cero grados
celsius en agua que estará a cero grados
celsius y ahora pueden darse cuenta de
cómo funciona esto vamos a tomar esta
agua de 0 grados hasta que temperatura
no de hasta 160 sino hasta 100 grados
celsius ya que es en esta temperatura
cuando comienza a transformarse en vapor
recordamos que cada que hay un cambio de
fase tenemos que hacer una pausa y el
calor específico va a cambiar de valor
esta q que necesitamos aquí la
calculamos usando m por c por delta t
el calor específico del agua es 4.186
jules por kilogramo grados celsius del
tate es mi temperatura final 100 grados
celsius menos mi temperatura inicial que
es 0 grados y nos da un millón 255 1800
jules y ahora que comenzamos a
transformar esa agua en vapor que tanto
calor nos va a requerir transformar toda
el agua en vapor es un cambio de fase
tenemos que usar esta otra fórmula q
igual a m por l m es 3 kilogramos
el calor latente de la vaporización del
agua es de 2 millones 260 mil jules por
kilogramos celsius
el resultado es
6 millones 780 mil jules para
transformar esta agua en vapor pero
tenemos que hacer una cosa más ya que
tenemos este vapor a 100 grados celsius
pero no queremos llevar a vapor con una
temperatura de 160 grados celsius por lo
que tenemos que volver a usar la fórmula
de q igual a m por ser el tate la masa
del vapor es de 3 kilogramos
el calor específico del vapor es de 2010
jules por kilogramo grados celsius
la temperatura final es 160 grados
- la temperatura inicial que es de 100
grados lo que nos da 361 1800 jules y
esto es todo el calor que necesitamos
para lograr transformar ese cubo de
hielo que está a menos 40 grados celsius
en vapor de agua que tiene 160 grados
celsius de temperatura